ABDUL KINADIYIL: Hello.
I'm Abdul Haseen Kinadiyil,
Solution Architect at Google
Cloud, specialized in Apigee.
In this session, we are going to
discuss how API management play
a critical role in your
application modernization
journey.
I'm joined by Chuck Rhoades
from Pizza Hut in this session.
Chuck, can you talk a little bit
about your role at Pizza Hut?
CHUCK RHOADES: Sure, Abdul.
Hi, I'm Chuck Rhoades.
I am the Director of E-Commerce
Technology for Pizza Hut US.
So I've been doing a lot of work
on modernizing our platforms
and in particular,
implementing Apigee
as part of our tech strategy.
So back to you, Abdul.
ABDUL KINADIYIL: Thanks.
This is the agenda
for today's session.
First, we will see
the trends and pattern
in application modernization.
Moving to a microservices
architecture
is essential in your
modernization journey.
We will discuss what are the
key aspects of microservices.
Then, Chuck will cover
the use cases and some
of the challenges
the team encountered
in the modernization effort.
Then we'll take a look
at what API management
and Apigee platform
brings to the table
when it comes to modernizing
your applications.
Today's customer needs
a seamless experience
across devices.
As a customer, I may start
an e-commerce transaction
on my smartphone.
And then later, I may
move to a wiser system,
such as Google Home.
Then I may complete that
order on my Google watch
at the end of the day.
The customer is expecting
seamless experience
across these devices.
The legacy applications that
we have in the enterprises
are not meeting those demands.
What are the requirements
for the modern applications?
From the business
perspective, you
want to increase revenue
from the business channels.
And you also want to open
up new business channels.
However, developers--
the developers
want to build application
and deploy more frequently.
We already saw the end users
want seamless experience
across these devices.
That brings us to the
composable enterprises.
Every organization
out there is embracing
digital transformation
and moving
to a composable enterprise.
That means today, you may have
a lot of monolith applications
with business capabilities.
You may want to expose
these business capabilities
independently.
And then, your
citizen developers,
partners, third-party
developers will
be able to leverage those
business capabilities
and create new experience
to your end users.
How do you modernize
your application?
The answer is moving towards
a microservices architecture.
Let's see what are the key
aspects of microservices.
The first one is composability
and replaceability.
That means you can take
these microservices,
package them differently, and
give different experiences
to our end users.
You can replace one version of
the microservice with other.
Technology heterogeneity--
that means you can develop
microservices using
different technologies.
One can be using Java and
other can be using Python.
You can scale these
microservices independently
of each other.
And you are partitioning
that big task
to smaller pieces,
when you move to
a microservices architecture.
You will have focused
teams dedicated
to manage these
microservices that
will allow you to move faster
and reduce the time to market.
So when you are modernizing
your monolith application
and moving to a
microservices architecture,
this may be your future state
that you are envisioning
for your application.
You may have an e-commerce
monolith application
with UI, then user
authentication, order
management, inventory
lookup, et cetera.
You want to take each
of those capabilities
and move to independent
microservices.
But the reality could
be somewhere in between,
meaning you may still
have to leverage
some of the capabilities
from the legacy monolith
application.
And some well-understood
capabilities
such as inventory
management or order
look up from the inventory--
from the e-commerce application
will be moved to the
microservices architecture.
Now, let me turn to Chuck.
And let's hear from Chuck, how
did the modernization journey
start for Pizza Hut, and what
are the challenges the team had
in the early stages?
CHUCK RHOADES: Thanks, Abdul.
Much as Abdul has described,
where we started out
on our modernization
journey was a mixture
of a lot of the different
worlds that Abdul
has described and talked about.
In the center of our
e-commerce platform
was an e-commerce core
monolith application
that serviced all of the
major purposes and components
of e-commerce
technology, as well
as a lot of back-end reporting
capabilities, data ingestion,
and things like that.
In addition to that,
we had started creating
several internal service APIs.
Different components focused
on some parts of our technology
like localizing customer
to the appropriate store
for deliveries or carry-outs
and other things around Delivery
Tracker and other
pieces that we built
more recently in a more
modern, microservice-centric
architecture.
And then in addition
to that, we have
things like our BI platforms,
store communication,
back of house
systems, POSs, really
a complicated and
wide-spanning technology stack,
making up all of our
infrastructure for our commerce
business.
In the beginning,
where we started from,
these technologies didn't
have a common way for us
to use or access them.
And so lots of connections
exist between all
of the different
components and pieces.
There many different ways of
accessing different components.
Some of them are through
a modern idea of an API.
Some are very older types of
technologies and approaches
with TCP sockets or other
transport technologies,
with no standards around how
we would access and utilize
all of these services.
So one of the first things
we really focused on
was creating an API Facade
and security around our APIs.
We did that by implementing
Apigee, which very quickly gave
us the ability to establish a
common authentication structure
and strategy with a common
security and authentication
model, across all of
the things that we
were converting into APIs.
Along with that was
building out an API
layer over the top of the
e-commerce core so that
we could then plug all of the
functionality of that core
into the new API gateway
layer that we had developed.
This let us do two
things that were really
important for promoting
the adoption of those APIs
as we moved forward.
One, we were able to use
Apigee's built-in developer
portal technology to very
quickly and easily create a way
to share the Swagger
documentation and the API
schema spec
information around that
with the consumers of
the API within Pizza Hut.
So any future client
work that was being done
could very quickly and easily
adopt and take advantage
of those new APIs,
rather than going
through the old ways of
integrating with the systems.
Second, it allowed us to bring
a really good, clear point
of view on what all of the
APIs and different technology
points we had in the
system and start planning
for how we could
modernize and bring
those systems along the path of
becoming really future state,
microservice-oriented
architecture.
So with that, we want
to talk a little bit
about what that modernization
journey can look like.
There can be many paths
of getting from where you
are today and over onto Cloud.
As we illustrate in
this information here,
you can start out on-prem.
But sometimes, you start
out with lifted and shifted
technologies sitting
in the Cloud,
where you've taken a
legacy technology stack.
You may have moved it
into a cloud provider,
but you haven't really
modernized that technology.
For Pizza Hut, we did a
little bit of all of these.
We had some places
where we were very--
we were in a position
to take a service
and go ahead and
start from the ground
up of breaking that down
in the microservices
and carrying it forward.
Other places we needed to shift
technology over into the Cloud,
so that we could then begin
doing the breakdown there.
One of the really
valuable things
about having the API
management layer in place
is it enables you to use all
of these different journeys
or a mixture of them
at the same time.
And so I'm going hand
it back over to Abdul,
and he's going to talk
to you a little bit more
about API management.
ABDUL KINADIYIL: Thanks, Chuck.
You may have heard from
Chuck that API management was
a critical aspect in their
modernization effort.
Apigee, the API
management platform,
allows you to establish a
relationship between consumer
developers and your
service producers,
such as legacy application team
or cloud-native application
team.
Apigee will allow you to expose
your business capabilities
as nice APIs, using the
features such as security,
then bot detection,
mediation of protocol
from SOAP to REST and
REST to SOAP, then
operation management,
developer portal, et cetera.
The developer portal
is a key feature
within the Apigee platform.
It will allow your
consumer developers
to interact with the APIs,
see the catalog of APIs,
register within the
developer portal,
and start consuming the APIs.
This gives a
first-class developer
experience to your
consumer developers
on the day one of your
modernization journey.
Now let's see what are
the patterns when you are
modernizing your application.
The first one is
service modernization.
In this pattern, you have
a legacy service running
in your on-premise data center.
And you are putting an
API facade on top of it
and leveraging the capabilities
from that Apigee API management
platform--
such as API analytics, then bot
detection, protocol mediation,
et cetera--
and then exposing a nice
interface to your consumer
developers.
This gives a better experience
for end users and consumer
developers.
The next one is hybrid
application, in which
you have the legacy service.
You may run this legacy service
within your on-premise data
center using a modern
infrastructure service,
such as Kubernetes Engine.
And then you may
combine that experience
with some other
good technologies
that Google Cloud offers, such
as data loss prevention, cloud
storage, artificial
intelligence, and machine
learning.
This gives an
enriched experience
to your consumer
developers and end users.
They are not actually
aware of the fact
that they are
interacting with a legacy
service behind the scenes.
The third pattern is
cloud-native application.
You may have
Greenfield applications
that you are developing using
cloud-native technologies.
You can leverage cloud
infrastructure services,
such as Google Kubernetes
Engine, Compute Engine.
You can develop serverless
application using Cloud Run.
And then you can leverage
the CI/CD capabilities
using Cloud Build.
And here you can still leverage
some of the cloud services,
such as artificial intelligence,
Firestore, then cloud storage.
So in this case,
your end consumer
and consumer developers are
getting a modern experience.
Some applications, you may
take these patterns as stages.
The stage one, you
have a legacy service.
And then you are
modernizing it, then
moving to stage two, hybrid
application, and the stage
three, cloud-native application.
Other applications
you may directly
jump to cloud-native
or hybrid application.
That's perfectly fine.
It is not one size fits all.
You can actually take multiple
path to your destination.
Now let's hear more
from Chuck on how
did the team at
Pizza Hut decompose
their monolith
application and move
towards a microservices
architecture.
CHUCK RHOADES: Thanks, Abdul.
As we talked about before, once
we had an API gateway in place
that we could use to bring all
of our connections and traffic
into our platform,
that really enabled
us to start looking
at how we wanted
to break that
e-commerce core down
and how we wanted to start
transforming a lot of that
into microservice technology.
It gave us a lot of
flexibility in doing so.
Because once we had
established the facade for what
that API was going to look
like through the gateway, how
we enabled that with
the services behind it
was much more flexible and had
a lot more room for change.
So we started by taking small
pieces of that architecture
that we could really make
independent and run separately.
All the while, we could
keep the functionality
in the monolithic core
that needed to stay there
for a longer period of time.
In addition to
this, this allowed
us to tie these platforms
into the other services
that we were running with
our internal service APIs
and platforms and still be
able to control and manage
all of the traffic going through
those APIs, as we went along.
Now, one of the things
you may have learned--
if you've already been through
a microservices migration
yourself or some good tip
for you as you move into that
world--
is the visibility and management
becomes a really important
component of what you're
doing with your microservices,
as you move through
one of these journeys.
With all of these new services
interacting and coming together
to provide data and
capabilities to your customers,
where that traffic goes and how
it flows through your system
can become really complicated.
Fortunately, we were able to
use a lot of the capabilities
in Apigee along with some
of the SRE principles
around golden signals to
capture the telemetry we needed
and get that to our
logging infrastructure
so that we can see
exactly what is going on
from service to service.
With that, using Apigee
and a combination
of other technologies,
we're also
able to manage that mesh in
how those services integrate
and interact with one another.
Now, Abdul is going to talk
you through a few more things
about some of the capabilities
for service mesh management
in Apigee, available today.
ABDUL KINADIYIL: Thanks, Chuck.
So you may have heard
from Chuck that when
you have a lot of microservices,
that can become unmanageable.
So Envoy is an open
source component
that is popular in service
mesh and microservices world.
It actually allows you
to dynamically route
the requests, then
distribute it, tracing,
and then observability
to your microservices.
It also gives you support
for HTTP protocol,
gRPC protocol, et cetera.
Apigee has an Envoy adapter.
And that gives you an ability
to enforce security policies
across the board in a
more consistent manner,
using app keys
and auth protocol.
It will allow you to
throttle the microservices
in a more consistent manner,
using distributed quota.
You can collect analytics data
across microservices running
in clusters and regions.
In summary, let's
take a look at what
are the some of the
challenges that we have
seen across customers,
when they are modernizing
the application?
The first one is
business continuity.
When you are modernizing
your application,
your consumer
developers and end users
should be able to interact
with your services
without any disruption.
Then, when you
move the workloads
from your on-premise
data center to the Cloud,
then the data can be
located everywhere.
That means on-premise
data center, public cloud,
or edge network.
The security should not be
compromised when you are
modernizing your application.
Visibility is a key aspect.
You should be able to know
how much of your traffic
is going to the legacy services
within your on-premise data
centers, versus the modern
microservices in Cloud.
You should be able
to interoperate
between the legacy service
and modern microservices.
And then you should be able
to enforce security policies
across microservices,
and you should
be able to throttle those
services without any problem.
How Apigee can help here?
Apigee will allow you to
connect between the legacy
service and microservices.
It hides the
modernization complexity
from your end users and
consumer developers.
You can enforce
security policies
more a consistent
manner, across the board.
It will allow you to mediate
between cloud protocol, as well
as enterprise security protocol.
You can integrate with
existing IdP systems
that you have in
your enterprise.
Visibility is a key aspect.
You can use Apigee
dashboard to view
the traffic that is going
to your legacy services,
versus microservices.
Apigee will allow you to
put an API facade in front
of the microservices, so
your consumer developers
has a nice experience when
interacting with those APIs.
You can manage
your microservices
in a more consistent manner
by enforcing security policies
across clusters and across
region using Apigee Envoy
adaptor.
You can also collect
analytics data
and then view them in
a single pane of glass,
which is Apigee dashboard.
So where does Apigee
and API management
fits in your technology
stack for modernizing
your application?
Google Anthos is
a great technology
to use when you are
modernizing your application.
You can leverage the
infrastructure service,
such as Google
Kubernetes Engine.
Then you can leverage the
dynamic routing capability,
distributed tracing,
observability,
using the service mesh.
And you can also develop the
serverless technology app,
using the Cloud Run.
API management sits on top of
this entire technology stack.
It allows you to
establish a relationship
between your consumer developers
and service producers.
You can build an ecosystem
of your consumer apps
and developers.
You can open up new
business channels,
as you are exposing
your business
capabilities as nice APIs.
It gives you a platform
with security and operations
capability to manage your
microservices across regions
and across clusters.
Before we wrap up,
let's take a look
at what are the key
benefits that you
get by leveraging API
management in your application
modernization journey.
The first one is, you will be
able to discover new business
channels.
You are exposing your business
capabilities as nice APIs.
And then your
consumer developers,
such as third-party developers,
partners, all your citizen
developers, will be
able to use these APIs
and create new experiences
for your end users.
That will open up new
business channels for you.
And then your
consumer developers
are getting a first-class
developer experience,
by coming to your
developer portal
and interacting with
the APIs on the day one
of your modernization journey.
They are looking at your
APIs, interacting with them,
and registering and
consuming those APIs.
You can access the legacy and
modern services seamlessly
using APIs.
You can measure
the cloud adoption
and how much of the traffic
is going to your legacy
services versus the
Microsoft service
that you are running
in the cloud.
Now let's hear from
Chuck, what are
the key benefits
the team experienced
when they used API management
in their modernization journey?
CHUCK RHOADES: Thanks, Abdul.
All of the benefits that
Abdul has discussed,
I could tell you
how Pizza Hut has
experienced those firsthand.
But key among those
is really our ability
to accelerate adoption and
speed to market with our APIs.
By having the API
facade in place,
it enables us both to
launch new services,
as well as migrate old
components into new services,
without affecting the
downstream consumers.
On top of that, having
the developer portal
available to expose those APIs
to our consuming developers who
can easily access the technology
and be interacting really
quickly has enabled
us to deliver features
into our mobile
platforms and websites
with a greater speed
than we ever have before.
So with that, I want to
say thank you to Abdul
for all of your hard work and
the Apigee team and Google,
in general.
Also thank you to
the Pizza Hut team
for the success we've made.
And thank you to all
of you watching today.
We appreciate your time
and hope the session has
been a great benefit to you.
So thank you, very much.